welcome back to cbs mornings you are
looking at queen elizabeth on the balcon
balcony rather buckingham palace viewing
the military parade that's kicking off
her four-day platinum jubilee she's
going inside now if you're wondering who
that man was standing beside her who
that man is standing beside her we were
too he is a duke of kent he is her
cousin he has served with her on many
military and civil ceremonies
they say he acts as the grand master and
carries out duties for the monarchy so
her platinum jubilee celebrates 70 years
the longest of any british monarch going
back more than a thousand years that's a
long time this is one more chance for
the british public to say thank you
ma'am that's what they call her but it
may not be the last time mark phillips
is outside buckingham palace with more
on this mark i'm so fascinated by all
things royal it's good to see her up and
about and looking so queenly good
morning to you
well it's a beautiful royal morning in
uh in london the sky is blue the sun is
shining and we won't see how much
weren't sure how much we'd see of the
queen on this event but this time this
trooping of the color ceremony which
just ended normally she goes to it it's
been suspended because of covid now it's
back but this time now given her age and
her slight infirmity this is a time when
it comes to her there's never been
anything like this platinum jubilee for
the simple reason that no british
monarch has ever reigned long enough to
have one but if anybody thought this was
a chance to throw one last big party for
queen elizabeth think again
you've got to be careful with the women
of this royal family never write them
off too soon
throwing a party for a 96 year old woman
who's been in the same job for 70 years
might seem like a last hurrah
but the hurrahs for this queen just keep
on coming
her mother did live to 101 after all i'm
here
the queen had been dialing back on her
public appearances even before what the
palace calls her mobility issues well as
you can see i moved
so it was left to prince charles to
officiate at the recent ceremonial
opening of parliament here
but to demonstrate who was still in
charge the queen not only sent her son
and heir she sent her hat
the royal presence endures even when the
top royal isn't present she's incredibly
dependable you can set your clock by her
robert hardman's latest book on the
queen is queen of our times and then
every now and then there are these
landmark moments which we call jubilees
and they're just a sort of moment for a
national party
the thing is though with uncanny timing
these national parties somehow seem to
come along just when the country could
use one
elizabeth's 1947 marriage to prince
philip provided a welcome diversion to
the grim business of britain's post-war
reconstruction
[Music]
her coronation in 1953 gently sets this
splendid emblem on the queen's head the
first to be televised provided some
imperial glitter at a time when it was
becoming clear the days of empire were
fading forever
and so it went her first jubilee had saw
the jubilee in 1977 britain was nearly
bankrupt i mean that really was we did
need a party then um this time obviously
we're coming out of a pandemic we've got
family issues and and now that you know
the queen is in her 10th decade so it's
just a very different kind of party and
it will have a very different kind of
party piece
remember those big family photos on the
buckingham palace balcony always a
snapshot of the era forget them this
time it will only be so-called working
royals harry and megan in self-imposed
exile in california gone
prince andrew in disgrace for his
association with the child sex
trafficker jeffrey epstein
gone
so this time it's only charles and
camilla william kate and the kids edward
and sophie's family and a few others
still in the royal good books and of
course there's no prince phillip
it is a sign of how things have changed
the monarchy has evolved i mean you look
at the the court when she came to the
throne and it was still
edwardian if not victorian it was still
run by sort of bumbling
aristocrats uh and and um i mean you
know
the decor the uniforms the attitudes
hadn't really changed in 100 years i
named the ship britannia
the queen though
for all she's been through has not
really changed when she came to the
throne she vowed to live a lifetime of
duty and that lifetime ain't over i
think she's already looking forward to
beating the one record she hasn't broken
yet which comes in a couple of years
when she beats louis xiv of france for
the
all-time reigning record he had a head
start as a boy king
she was a 25 year old mother of two so
uh you know she had she had a bit of
catching up to do
and she's almost there i remember
attending her mother's 100th birthday
party it was a hell of a party i think
it'll be an even bigger one for her with
the added benefit of beating the french
exactly then there is literally no other
record left
so it seems the takeaway from this four
day party weekend is save something for
the next one tony
mark i don't know if you intended to do
it but you got me excited about a thing
i was not
that was a very good piece you want to
go to the party right i do want to go to
a party uh she's done gold she's done
diamond uh now platinum i don't know
what's next but i wouldn't count her out
i know go back to mark so he can set the
scene and tell us what it's like to be
there mark what's it like to be there i
i'm excited looking at it through the
screen honestly
i was trying to figure out this morning
how many of these have been around for
and it's too many actually to count but
it goes back over four decades
something funny happens around here
there's something in the air around here
you think not another one and then you
show up and it's a great show and
there's a genuine feeling of of
affection and uh and the party's just
starting so let's all have a great
weekend
yeah celebration she's so beloved enjoy
mark and it's nice to celebrate
something have some fun mark have some
fun for us